[Music]
would it surprise you to know that a
sheepdog
is better at math than you are that's
how they're doing this
algorithmic math herding requires the
type of thinking that's often used in
engineering
sheepdogs are uniquely great herders
because they naturally
think algorithmically sheepdogs know
that sheep
behave according to the selfish herd
principle which means
when there's a perceived threat an
individual seeks cover
by pushing deep into the herd this acts
as a centripetal force
pulling the rest of the herd inward on
itself a collie
can analyze the state of a herd like its
mood and proximity of the sheep to each
other
then quickly decide on an action from a
limited choice of barking
eye contact and circling the animals if
you're not ready to get a sheepdog to
take your engineering exam for you yet
check this out the algorithmic
strategies that sheepdogs use
are so effective that they're being
considered for use as human crowd
control so what are some commands you
can use to herd sheep with your sheepdog
dog's herding skills originally came
from their ancestral predatory behavior
through training and selective breeding
humans have modified dogs to retain
their hunting skills
but eliminate their killing behavior
some breeds like the australian cattle
dog
are called healers because they hurt by
nipping at animals heels
other breeds like the border collie are
called headers because they run in front
of the animals and stare them down
people and dogs co-evolved and have a
long history of working together
humans work with sheepdogs to herd by
using voice commands
hand signals or a combination of both
here are some common commands that you
can yell to a sheepdog to try hurting
your own children
fine means locate the herd and keep them
in place until the shepherd arrives
cast means gather the animals into a
cohesive group
back means give the animals some room so
they don't get overly stressed
and that'll do means stop
working and return to the shepherd your
mom is going to kill us
means everybody hide popular sheep
herding breeds include
collies corgis and of course sheepdogs
most herding dogs are now just pets
who've never even seen a sheep but
their herding instincts remain strong
where no sheep exists to keep them busy
your pet herding dog will round up your
kids into corners or tight circles
wait don't speed to a pet store yet
herding dogs need pet owners who are
skilled at training
and could give them work that rewards
their instincts or they won't be happy
healthy or good family pets the american
kennel club
currently recognizes 25 breeds for being
excellent herders
these dogs vary in size and appearance
from the australian catalog
to the swedish valhun but they share the
ability to shepherd creatures much
larger than themselves
the most popular is the border collie
which is known for its intelligence and
eagerness to please its handlers
using advanced math principles and
herding you into a corner
that's what shepard dogs do and that's
what makes them
crazy creatures